want to touch a little bit more on this
DeSantis announcement DeSantis did it in
this call this Twitter spaces with Elon
Musk and there were some tech glitches
and it was a little bit flat you know if
I had to be critical of the announcement
I would say there wasn't a ton of energy
it obviously just lacked the enthusiasm
that a live event could generate that
said it's not a total knock on DeSantis
president Trump's announcement for his
2024 campaign also was kind of flat Tim
Scott's recent announcement the
microphone broke I'm not convinced that
presidential campaign announcements
really matter at all do you remember any
of them I vaguely remember Obama's
Reagan 1980 I kind of remember the
Statue of Liberty nobody really
remembers these things it doesn't really
matter the question is can they go the
distance